[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by darcy cardin aka
greta and melanie field aka joe in a
league of their own which drops the full
season friday on prime video how you
guys doing today good so good how are
you
great so my first question actually is
for darcy darcy with the little things
that's you with the little things though
with the batting stance and the form
when you're throwing in the show how
were those kind of choices made by you
um
thank you for even thinking that they
were a choice
um i mean i guess we did you know
not that it was completely not a choice
but we um
we
some of us had a little bit of
experience with baseball prior to the
show some of us didn't melanie and i
both played as kids and i played like
through high school and then we
trained for months you know with a real
live coach and real life baseball
players that were helping us with every
little detail and
um
you know i think i infused if i like may
i infused
some darcy style onto that greta stance
or you know
i um
and i and i'm saying that because like i
don't know how to do it anyway
yeah but yeah i'll make it pretend i'll
pretend it was a choice it was absolute
choice no i like that yeah i want to
hear that there's some darcy in that uh
choices for those kind of stance and
stuff now
melanie you had mentioned in an
instagram post that you went to a
batting cage to prepare for your
audition are they as scary as i remember
and had that process go for you
so yeah they're terrifying um
ball fly
it's just ball and like you know you can
adjust the speed and stuff and they tell
you when you get your bat but it just
goes in when you're out the other so the
first like hour because yes i stayed for
a very long time my hands were bleeding
yeah by the end i was like well now i'm
not gonna be able to do the audition i'm
like i can't hold him out but eventually
this guy working behind the counter took
pity on me and he came out and he's like
do you want some help i was like yes
please eddie like he taught me some
things that where i actually started
making like consistent contacts i mean
you owe him
honestly
i'm gonna find that guy
i love that too like how exciting is the
show's coming up but also the stuff
that's coming around it with you guys
that
darcy you got to throw out the first
pitch at a pirates game which is so cool
so
do you have a favorite baseball team and
are you a fan of watching mlb in general
yeah i i grew up in a big a's household
okay
um we
we were i like lucked out and sort of
being like a kid when the a's were doing
really well so um i was like a mark mark
mcguire jose could say go kid i got i
got like some really good you know
like the bash brothers the like the
battle of the bay oh yeah yeah yeah um
so i'm and uh yeah i'm really into like
1990 a's and then
i mean i love watching baseball i've
been to a couple games this season
i i don't i don't have a team like i i
don't really follow you know the players
as much as it's really fun to follow
players like it's not fun when you have
a team yeah i think so and i think so
but it you know it has to like come
naturally i guess yeah
yeah no that that's awesome and it's
good to hear that you like baseball too
being in this that always i think gets
people excited to see that too it's
that's the genre and
uh melanie i'm gonna put you on the spot
what was the best thing about darcy as a
scene partner but there's an option of
what was the worst thing just kidding
don't okay i would never there was no
worse thing i totally can't i don't care
the worst thing is that it's the worst
thing is that we don't do it anymore i
like
put me
put me in a scene with darcy any day our
chemistry from the second i met her was
undeniable
and definitely allowed me to do my best
work and there was no worse parts only
great parts it felt pretty magical yeah
from really truly from like from
melanie's audition or chemistry test
like it was just without a doubt this
friendship was you know was already
solid even though we had just met and
then that only continued to this very
moment but all through filming it was
when especially whenever it was just
our little two-person scenes we were
pretty thrilled yeah yeah yeah i mean
look you heard it from everybody watch
darcy and melanie just be magical on
screen like they're saying oops and just
kidding
magic and they're gonna hit it out of
the park in a league of their own full
season drops friday on prime video thank
you guys so much for joining me today
talk to you in the future thanks guys
okay bye